in 2016 Tesla CEO Elon Musk posted this
tweet implying that the model S could
temporarily float like a boat it was a
bold claim to make and some people were
genuinely impressed but others well they
were skeptical until this happened soon
we might no longer have to settle for a
floating Model S very soon we might have
a yacht a 700 million dollar
hydropowered and solar charge Tesla
yacht that is as epic as you'd expect
any Tesla product to be before we set
sail there are two things that you must
know first the Tesla yacht is a
breathtaking work of a marine
engineering Marvel it's like Art and
Science had a Seaborn baby and frankly I
am not surprised the Tesla company has
shown that they not only innovate in
their approach to Machinery they are
also precise when it comes to their
style we'll talk about it more in a
second but we need to address the second
point you must know there is no Tesla
yacht at least not at the moment and I
promise you that this isn't some click
bait Rabbit Hole this is not a scam the
fact is designs of the yacht exist at
the moment it's still going through its
conceptual phase in the hands of dhruv
Pasad a designer who worked in the Tesla
design team in the past so bear that in
mind as we dive into the details of this
beautiful Beast good good now let's
begin Tesla has had its fair share of
curious ventures in its relatively Short
History ever since they came onto the
scene in the early 2000s and ever since
musk took control of the company we've
seen everything from electric cars to
futuristic looking pickup trucks to
creating an entire energy focused
subdivision that's threatened to
redefine how we consume power so if you
take all of that into consideration it's
not all that far-fetched that the
electric car company would try their
hand at an electric yacht the Tesla
yacht is quirky and stunning quirky
because the designer Drew Prasad took
major Inspirations from the shape of a
giant squid when he was creating its
Sleek looking structure and stunning
because unlike other Yachts out there
this one will be as quiet as anything
with a Tesla logo should be oh you had
no idea Yachts are noisy
well here's a reference for you for
educational purposes and this is from a
small one the reason the Tesla yacht
won't sound like that is all thanks to
the electric Machinery powering it and
we will talk about it in a bit we'll
also cover for who and why it was
designed in the first place but for now
let's jump into the stuff we know the
people love to see specs exteriors and
interior based on the designs the Tesla
yacht will be sleek and Incredibly
modern the Tesla super yacht will also
measure a very economical 131 feet or 40
meters across its entire length by
contrast this is a little troubling
because if you know anything about
Yachts you know that these dimensions
are incredibly short by any standard
especially for a yacht that would
supposedly cost 700 million dollars you
don't believe me here's a list of the
world's longest Yachts if we were to
rank the Tesla yacht on this same list
it would be well give me a second
um nowhere the last yacht on this list
is at least 246 feet which is about 75
meters so ask me why am I still calling
it a super yacht well the answer is
simple it's price tag I don't think I
know anyone who can afford a 700 million
dollar yacht and I know quite a lot of
people but we're not done yet things get
a little more interesting because aside
from its surprisingly brief length and
despite its nine-figure valuation the
super yacht houses only two decks and
four lounges two decks that's a bummer I
mean if you aren't already reeling in
shock and stuttering in disbelief like
me then you might know what this means
but don't worry I'll break it down if we
choose to rank Yachts based on how much
they cost the Tesla yacht would rank
above Azam a 600 million dollar ship
owned by an Abu Dhabi billionaire and
despite costing a hundred million less
the Azam has seven decks and 50 Suites
that's at least three times more decks
and many times more interior space than
the Tesla yacht offers okay so I'll step
into the shoes of a Tesla superfan for a
second and say it's probably just a
question of exclusivity this could be a
yacht for introverted billionaires maybe
whoever chooses to buy it is the type
that won't want to have visitors wants
to keep it small call it a private super
yacht that would make sense good good
now Beyond its insane price tag and
economical space it also Sports a
deceptively narrow design that makes it
both stylish and aerodynamic but more
importantly it allows it to move faster
in the water while retaining its
stunning appearance it also has a sharp
narrow tip with a flat wide end opening
to one of its lounges and it has Windows
large panoramic windows that run almost
the entire length of the craft
Illuminating its Interiors with natural
lighting while giving anyone that can
afford to own it a breathtaking view of
the sunset the Tesla yacht will also
feature a unique luxurious and modern
interior the upper deck will feature a
massive open space that can be used for
anything from massive parties to events
there will also be a bar and a
convenient sitting area a large TV
screen on one end and a massive solar
panel that feeds power to the entire
boat more on that later the other end
will hold the battery indicator and both
can be sheltered from strong weather
conditions with a controlled shutter
door there will also be a lounge area at
the stern that comes with comfortable
deck chairs and a Jacuzzi within there
are two bedrooms which will be furnished
luxuriously according to the tastes of
the Tesla brand obviously and this goes
without being said there will also be
spaces for the cabin crew a kitchen a
swimming pool and bathrooms the lower
deck will share a lot of features with
the upper deck including a living area
with seats hidden in tables that pop out
at the push of a button and finally it
will also come with a fully furnished
Spa along with massage tables and a
steam room that brings another notch of
luxury to the yacht a lot of features
are still under wraps and there is still
a lot that will be revealed with time
but for now you can be sure that Tesla
will go all out on the power system they
have enough experience that would give
them enough advantage to set them ahead
of the game that Advantage is their
history of making sustainable Electric
Power Systems that have powered not only
electric cars all over the world but
thousands of homes Across America with
their energy Focus sub Vision Tesla has
introduced a range of Energy Products
like the power wall that have disrupted
the traditional energy industry devices
like the power wall store energy
generated from solar panels or grids for
its users to utilize in down periods or
in the event of an outage it is clean
and efficient two things that yacht
builders all over the world have
struggled with Millions have been spent
on research and development but it seems
Tesla might be the ones to crack the
code their eco-friendly Power Systems
will not only make the Yachts safe for
the waters but it will also prevent the
vessel's engines from hydrolocking
hydrolocks happen when a yacht's motor
engine gets too much water in them but
since the design ensures that the yacht
won't have any openings that the blue
Seas could exploit The Vessel will be
safe from that at the very top of the
yacht will sit a customized solar panel
that I mentioned earlier which will be
enough to charge the battery even while
the yacht is stationary and at the
bottom there will be turbines that can
drive the yacht to speeds of up to 70
knots by producing hydroelectricity
which will be circulated through to
power the yacht and charge the battery
tree this Loop mimics the system you
find in Tesla electric vehicles making
each one a powerful energy generator and
conserver this also means that the yacht
can eliminate the cost of fuel making
sure that it never gets stranded in the
middle of the sea now you must know that
if this yacht ever sees the light of day
it won't be the first at least from a
technical perspective in 2021 knee-deck
a Japanese company in the electric motor
industry reported that it installed an
electric power system in a 165-foot
yacht and it had worked just fine but in
the same breath Dr Charles kuaman a lead
engineer at Tesla has also tweaked his
personal yacht and Elon GT5 to an
electric vessel so it's becoming a
growing Trend that might just need a
heavyweight like Tesla to finally make a
technological statement can you see now
why the concept of an electric yacht is
not so far-fetched at least not with
people like Dr Charles on the Tesla team
okay it's time to address the price tag
because I don't think we've spoken
enough about it 700 million dollars is a
whole lot of money there I said it I've
made made calls and I still don't think
I have friends that can afford this
truth is there aren't many yachts in the
world that have gone past that price
point in fact if you're counting Yachts
that actually exist there is only one
Roman abramovich's eclipse and it costs
an astronomical 1.5 billion dollars for
reasons we cannot begin to break down in
this video so in what Universe do we see
Elon making a Tesla ship this expensive
personally I think there is a chance but
take everything we've said here with two
grains of salt because I think most if
not all the specs will change the boat
will be longer the price tag might be
lower the Innovation more revolutionary
and precise like I said a lot will
change and maybe that's why Elon hasn't
publicly endorsed or even made a comment
about the 700 million dollar Tesla yacht
wait so does that mean the yacht might
never happen not so fast Elon has also
not disowned the yacht and this is odd
because when you consider the fact that
the Tesla boss is the internet's biggest
troll you'll know that there is no way
he hasn't heard of the concept yacht and
this also means that his silence is a
deliberate choice another reason why I'm
sure Elon is aware of this Uber
expensive electric sea vessel is because
Drew Prasad The Man Behind the concept
yacht has worked with Tesla's product
design team in the past he most
certainly Falls somewhere under musk's
radar so while Elon allegedly has had
little to nothing to do with the design
or ideation of prasad's concept tesliat
I wouldn't be too surprised if one day
we have an electric Sea Beast under the
Tesla Banner quietly cruising the Open
Seas